now there are other situations we can
run into too for example let's say we
have two robots that are shooting at
each other through a wall maybe they're
not the brightest robots in the world or
maybe they are let's take a closer look
at this situation we have a few
different bounding boxes consider we
have this wall made up of a few bounding
boxes and we also have the bounding box
of the rocket so let's say we have this
rocket here and in one time step of the
physics engine it is on this side of the
wall but on the next time step of the
wall now everything in our physics
engine happens at discrete steps so
there's no point at which this bounding
box and this bounding box intersect so
then which bounding box should we use do
we want to end up using this bounding
box right here or maybe we should
calculate some halfway point between the
two right here and use that bounding box
or maybe we want to use the entire swept
area swept out between the two time
steps and use that instead now the box
I've drawn is a little bit bigger than
the path that would be swept out between
these two time steps which of these do
you think that we should use to properly
calculate collisions check whichever
single one you think is appropriate